في غضون ثلاثه اسابيع يستعد الاتحاد
الاوروبي لحضري جميع واردات الوقود الروسي
بشكل كلي في محاوله لمعاقبه موسكو على
عمليتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا ففي العام
الماضي وحده استورد الاتحاد الاوروبي نحو
220 مليون برميل من منتجات الديزل
المنقوله بحرا من روسيا وفقا بياناته شركه
البريطانيه المتخصصه في تتبعي ناقلات
النفط ويمثل ايجاد بديل لهذا القدر من
الوقود الروسي الذي يعادل 14 الف مسبح
الاولمبي مليء بالديزل تحديا كبيرا كون
روسيا المصدر الخارجي الاكبر والوحيد
للكتله
[موسيقى]
منذ ديسمبر العمل ماضي خفض الاتحاد
الاوروبي نسبه استيراد الوقود الروسي
المنقوله بحرا الى حوالي 40 بالمئه يرجع
ذلك الجزئيا الى زياده الشحنات المنقوله
من السعوديه والهند ووفقا لوكالتي بلومبرج
يعد الشرق الاوسط المكانه الاكثر وضوحا
الذي يمكن ان تحصل منه اوروبا على المزيد
من الوقود لقربه من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وخاصه الدول المطله على البحر المتوسط
بالاضافه الى امتلاكه معامل تكرير حديثه
قادره على انتاج الملايين من براميل
الوقود
[موسيقى]
قد تكون الصين المصدر المحتمل لاهم ولو
بشكل غير مباشر حصته تصدير الوقود الاولى
للصين في عام 2023 ارتفعت بنسبه حوالي 50
في المئه مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من العام
السابق خبراء الشارو الا ان بكين هي التي
تتحكم في فائد طاقه التكرير العالمي مع
توقعات بان تتراوح صادرات الصين من وقود
الديزل بين 400,000 و600 الف برميل يوميا
خلال نصف الاول من العام الجاري وهذه كميه
مشابهه لكميه شحنات الوقود المنقوله بحرا
من روسيا التي قد يفقدها الاتحاد الاوروبي
وبريطانيا
رشا خياطه العربيه